was a number of teams that called after
that media blitz that that happened
right uh
but you know i never actively negotiated
with anybody
and with any team now did people call
absolutely
and um but yeah i'm not going to get
into specific teams but
uh yeah there was never ever
there was never ever a conversation you
know people think that trade talks
happen
you know like hey you just start
negotiating right away
there's a lot of calls that are very
very periphery calls
russ has been our quarterback for a good
while and we've got a long contract with
him
and when all of the conversation went
about trades and all that i knew what
the truth was
trade and russell and so uh um you know
that's
so we plan on him being here for a good
good while i don't know how many years
it is now but we're in great shape and
and a long future uh ahead of us is
shared
russ knows that and i know that we're
very clear about it's why it was really
obvious
that we just had to sit back and let the
you know the kind of the media take its
course with the topic and and uh
so we did and so we're in good shape and
and both very clear about that
chris as i said yesterday on pftpm the
packers got more for
their money when they hired a consultant
to tell them to use the phrase
foreseeable future
than the seahawks got for their money
when they hired a consultant who told
them to say
a good why a good while when when you
listen to pete's answer
it sounds like russell wilson's under
contract for 10 years
he's not he's under contract three more
seasons
21 22 23 and his agent mark rogers who
has no other nfl clients and therefore
drives a hard bargain with the seahawks
every time he always puts the squeeze on
the seahawks
with one year left we're two years away
from
russell wilson back on jimmy fallon and
jimmy fallon saying so you're going to
be the highest paid player in football
again
right that's what's going to happen so
they're going to have to pay him or
trade him in two years
i think the reality is at most they get
one more year
and after this year that's when
russell's either going to make his play
or they're going to have to come to
terms with reality but
you know a good while is the headline
when you listen to everything pete said
and he looked over to john schneider at
one point i mean i don't know maybe pete
just doesn't know how long russell
wilson is under contract
it's not well into the future it's three
seasons
two years from now they're either going
to extend him
or they're going to be entering their
lame duck year with russell wilson or
more likely they're going to be trading
him then
if they don't trade him before then yeah
i think that's that's where
i tend to lean i mean i think the one
thing is or or
i'll say for right now right is i think
we can close the door on a russell
wilson trade for this year
like it's not going to happen here any
time now otas training camp whatever
he's going to be the quarterback of the
seahawks for 2021 but i think after that
it's a coin flip i do
you know i mean there's just there's too
many media blitz i mean there was a
media blitz because your quarterback
made it to media blitz they know that
they were very good in how they handled
that
whole situation there you know even with
like how pete at the end is like
you know we always knew he was going to
be here so we just kind of let the media
talk about it and we knew it would die
down
no no no you just he's the one who did
it russell did it that's what i mean
russell did it and
i don't buy that you always knew he's
going to be here i think you guys are
just sitting there letting those phone
calls come in
going man is someone going to make us
some absurd offer that we can't turn
down
that's what i think but as we also too i
think what sheds light on that is
you know we talked about this back of
the time you know because the bears
tried to make it right the
the they tried to you know which which
we heard yeah they must have sent an
offer out there or anything like that
but seattle never
as john schneider said never really got
into real talks with anybody
uh so that should be able to keep him in
good faith with
russell wilson and everything like that
but i think that story's done here for
this year at least well
and i think here's why they never got
into any talks with anyone because
once you do that you
you got to trade him you can't say well
we negotiated then we decided to keep
him
once you you throw that that chum into
the water
it's done because russell wanted out
his agent wanted him out they saw an
opportunity
and as long as the seahawks kept the
door slammed shut and furniture
barricading the other side of it to any
trade discussions
there was really nothing they could do
the moment you open that door
it's over it's over just the question is
what deal are you going to get
from another team and i like it chris
because we had enough quarterback
movement this year
let's kick russell wilson and aaron
rodgers to next year okay
we know we know what's coming we know
what's going to drive
traffic and drive viewership it's going
to be what happens with aaron rodgers
what happens with russell wilson because
they both got i think we agree
one more year where they currently are i
i think so yeah i mean that's the way i
see it playing out and hey you know the
other thing too with the seahawks
uh i'm russell and john probably look at
it like i mean russell pete and john
john schneider they probably look at it
again too the the salary thing with
russell and how much money is going to
cost against their team and
them having to juggle all of that and
already being in a tight spot
that had to be another big part of this
puzzle to just go you know what it's
just too much we can't let a guy
go out the door and have this much dead
money on our cap right now
when he signed that contract two years
ago they gave him 35 million per year
top of the market at the time
i was told reliably and i still believe
it
entirely this is the last contract he's
going to sign
with the seattle seahawks and i believe
it because the next time around what are
they going to want they're going to want
46 million a year or whatever the top of
the market is two years from now i don't
know that anyone's going to pass
patrick mahomes in new money average uh
which is currently 45 million but
they're going to shoot for that and one
way or the other russell wilson is going
to end up in a place where
he gets to be the patrick mahomes and it
all runs through him that's what he
wants
that's why it was a problem that's why
it was an issue that's why we heard
let russ cook all year last year and as
i said earlier in the season
the message is let russ cook or you're
going to be baking him a farewell cake
and people scoffed well you can still
scoff
this the time for scoffing is going to
end in about a year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports